I'm talking to mr. Walter ellis who
worked on the sydney harbour bridge as
a holder up to remember
getting the job there. Mr.
Ellis. Yes i do. Yes. The former
ball maker. Sam harris asked me
to come down to milton's
point depot and you give me
a start. The first week that i was employed
there. I was running down bolts and
nuts and griese in them for the upper
structure in that week i was told one
morning by mr sam harris that i would be
going up in the cage to the top and he
gave me my mate who was a riveter and mr.
George stobart. As we went up
half way the crane driver.
In his joking way deliberately let
the brake or and used to make
a spence and i caught. I become terrified
of course other than that. Previously i
would never climb any higher
than say a peach tree or
a local tree. When i got to the top the
swivel of the hook was spending around
. And i was that terrified i did not know
how i would get off eventually somebody
help me out and through i
suppose bravado. I overcome the
situation but my first job was more
terrifying than that traveled up and the
cage. I was given
a twenty eight pound hammer. So knock
adrift through the side plate at the bridge
of the first chord which i did do and i
done it. Magnificently. From then on of
course i grew up with the bridge and it
had no fears for me. Can you remember you
were also holding up for a time when i was
a holder upper for the full term from the
first section to the fourteen section
with my mate. George stay about and what
was the job of holding up. How did you go
about it while the job of holding up was
catching a rabbit in the bucket from
a cooker. Which was white hot rivet
and i would put the rivet into
a hole hit it in with a hammer
and put the dolly which is
a machine that would rattle the
river up for the ball and make it
a river down on the other side and do you
remember or did you do in work at the
chords at all. I worked inside the chords
what they call the stitch plates. Now the
stitch plates were plates that joined two
chords together two sections together
which held 100 idea rivets which are
five eighths of an inch in diameter.
Now on these rivets. We have an inspector
who used to come up in the white coat
with
a small tack hammer one finger one side
and the tack and the other if it did make
any movement. He would put
a white cross on that rivet and we'd say
out of one hundred eighty. We'd have at
least replace another forty and how did
you replace them. How do you cut them out
first the way we cut them out was the river
though we'd use these riveting machine
where the kind of
a chisel which he would cut right through
the center of the rivet and then
we'd put. A wad. Whether on the
end of the handle which i used to
hit with
a hammer. They were breaking side the
rivet all off and then we'd put the rivet
hang onto the top of the river and knock
it right through and they would be
replaced when the conditions like inside
the cord when you were working in the the
conditions inside the cord
were rather hot and of course
. With the slag coming off the
rivet you would get burnt your
clothing would catch
a light which of course you'd put out with
their gloves but in today's standards. I
would not see an ironworker for
a riveter working under those conditions.
What sort of washing conditions did you
have you know how did you put your clothes
what to do what did you do for lunch and
that sort of thing. Well for luncheon. You
could have your you take your lunch onto
the bridge in the morning and have it out
there looking at the harbour and the
boats buying by or here go down to mess
rooms conditions as far as changing
or bathing or showering did not worry us
because we just walk off the job and go
home. Do you remember where did you live
then at that particular time i lived in
twenty six neutral street north sydney. I
didn't have to go to work. I'm not very
far no walking distance. Do you member
anything any stories that of things that
happened while you were up there. Well
one story was the beginning of the first
chord was
a man by the name of anderson who fell to
his step and they recovered his body. The
following morning had a
son. Have a son. Here is
a young married man. I think at that
time he lived and now and. We were
. I think i have it wrong. I always thought
that we went home that day but what
they eventually tire me today.
Here was that we're gave one half
a day's pay for his funeral. Here it
is and did live in narromine to stride
. Do you did you see him fall. I did not
see him fall and he saw the commotion. You
have an ear escapes yourself. I had
a very near escape and this one. I
must impress on you was that. Halfway
over on the middle section.
We were working on the
laterals which is in the middle of the
bridge on the bottom section of the top
chord and me being
a holder upper. I caught the river this
morning the place in the hole for my mate
to rivet down but unfortunately
i did not change my
spike piece which is at the bottom of
a piece of two inch water pipe must
be sharp to dig into the steel
where the top section which
is the plunger holds
a river that. Now this plant
this point being blunt.
When i turn the trigger on for there to go
through for the plunger it skated but it
took me with it and i went down from
the scaffolding roughly about six
foot. Which i hung on like grim
death being so young vigorous
. Nervous too. I think they were
riggers were in the vicinity
and they came racing over and they pulled
me up by the rubber hose and i regain my
footing on the scaffolding from then on of
course naturally i went home for the day
the following morning i backed up again.
Cause you be going vigorous good reflexes
. I was able to shape up the next day
without worrying about the day before you
member any other hard any dangerous
incidents. Well the only other dangerous
instance would be i never
actually seen anything but. On
a windy day it was very dangerous that if
you wasn't careful you could be blown off
the top of the cord. But of course i
suppose everybody realized this and we all
took precautions against it. Jim rennie
humorous things any funny things that
happened while you were working on the
bridge humorous things and funny things.
Well the only humorous and funny things i
saw was when mamie johnson flew over the
top of the harbour bridge and we all
waved our tills at it. If you want
to some humor senior. If you
can't think of anything else.
Well that's right. Staying
on this. You can't
have got. Staying in the same on the same
vein. We say. While you were up there.
What we did. If you needed to go the
toilet for instance. Well that's
a funny thing but the time it hit the
water. It would be descending rated. To
be nothing left to take that's no one
of us four hundred thirty two feet.
I'm not sure whether it's 4:30 to
from the railway or the bottom
a barge. But i know it was four hundred
thirty two feet at hyde hyde. High tide.
But if you done your business for you and
i did well by the time i got even halfway
down it would be dispersed to go and i think
i can hear a plane going over sending.